engage through very fast-paced
stimulating activities we focus on
things like photographic memory memory
training we do critical thinking skills
numeracy literacy storytelling etc so a
bit of everything well I've got a lot of
sort of capabilities that you don't
really realize like two notes are out
that she can count them she considered I
guess identify words three
it's a global approach know to develop
the whole brain the main purpose of
shitty day is not to create little
geniuses it's just to instill in the
Khilafah plan if they're having fun and
they're enjoying themselves I don't
think that you're pushing them she stops
having fun she might be doing it